Healthcare.gov works great now.
And millions of Americans have already gotten health insurance plans...
...and what we want is for people to know that you can get affordable healthcare.
And most young Americans right now, they're not covered.
And the truth is that they can get coverage,...
...all for what it costs you to pay your cell phone bill.
Is this what they mean by drones?
The point is that a lot of young people, they think they're invincible.
Did you say invisible?
No, no, not invisible; invincible,...
...meaning that they don't think they can get hurt.
I'm just saying that nobody could be invisible, if you had said invisible.
I understand that.
If they get that health insurance, they can really make a big difference,...
...and they've got until March 31st to sign up.
I don't have a computer so how does...
Well, then you can call 1-800-318-2596.
I don't have a phone, I'm off the grid,...
...I don't want you people like, looking at my texts, if you know what I mean?